Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à toutes et tous.
Je m’appelle Nassim Larfa, j’ai 26 ans
et je travaille au ministère
des Solidarités et de la Santé.
Soyez rassuré tout de suite, je ne viens
pas pour parler de crise sanitaire.
Ce dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui,
c'est de mon engagement associatif.
En effet, j’ai été engagé
pendant près de huit années
aux côtés de jeunes lycéens et lycéennes
devant réaliser un choix d’orientation.
Et durant cette expérience,
j’ai appris beaucoup de choses
sur cette notion de choix
que vous avez toutes et tous
été amenés à réaliser,
que ce soit dans votre vie universitaire
ou dans votre vie professionnelle.
Aujourd’hui, je veux
m’interroger avec vous
pour savoir comment mieux appréhender
et préparer ce choix.
L'adage nous dit que le seul mauvais
choix serait l'absence de choix.
Oui, que le seul mauvais choix
serait l'absence de choix.
Mais en réalité, cette notion de choix,
cette indication de choix,
ne doit-elle pas être questionnée
dans notre société ?
Sommes-nous toutes et tous égaux
face au choix,
que celui-ci soit scolaire à un moment
ou professionnel à un autre ?
Pouvons-nous tous l’appréhender
de la même manière ?
A travers ces questions,
vous avez déjà la réponse.
Non, puisque pour construire un choix,
il faut une stratégie.
Et souvent, ces stratégies
sont individuelles,
internes à l’histoire de chaque individu.
Je veux vous faire découvrir les moyens
qui ont amené des centaines de lycéens
et de lycéennes passés par l’association
à construire un choix qui répond à leur
ambition et surtout à leurs souhaits.
Pour cela, prenons deux exemples
de personnages fictifs.
Fictifs, mais pas tant que ça finalement.
D’un côté, un jeune lycéen, Samir, 17 ans.
De l’autre, une jeune fille,
Chloé, 18 ans,
étudiante en première année
d’école de droit.
Samir.
Samir est un jeune lycéen âgé de 17 ans,
qui a su transposer son ambition du
terrain de foot vers le terrain scolaire.
En effet, Samir veut être le meilleur
et il veut être le meilleur
partout et tout le temps.
Et force est de constater qu’il est
le meilleur partout et tout le temps.
En effet, Samir est ce qu’on appelle
un excellent élève,
capable d’avoir des bonnes notes aussi
bien en mathématiques qu’en français.
Mais pourtant, derrière ce jeune homme
en apparence sûr de lui,
se cache un lycéen
bridé par l’autocensure.
L’autocensure, qu’est-ce que c’est ?
Vous avez sans doute vous-même
été confronté à cette notion.
Vous savez,
c’est cette notion préventive
qu’on s’applique à soi-même
en se disant soit qu’on ne veut pas
rêver trop grand,
soit - et c’est le cas de Samir -
qu’on limite notre potentiel pour ne pas
être bridé par nos ambitions plus tard.
Et Samir se l’applique à lui-même.
Ainsi, Samir, en classe de terminale,
souhaite réussir.
D’un côté, il en est convaincu, il s’en
donne même les moyens à travers ses notes.
Mais il ne sait pas vraiment
ce qu’est réussir ni comment réussir.
Pourtant, et vous êtes déjà passé par là,
en grande majorité dans la salle,
le choix en classe de terminale
approche à grands pas pour Samir.
Il devra construire un choix
qui répond à ses ambitions
et qui correspond à son ambition
qu’il, comme je le disais,
a su transposer du terrain de foot
vers le terrain scolaire.
Prenons un autre exemple : Chloé.
Chloé, si on devait qualifier sa
situation, on la qualifierait sans doute
d’inversement proportionnelle
à celle de Samir.
En effet, Chloé est une jeune étudiante
en première année d’école de droit,
étudiante moyenne,
pour qui le choix d’orientation en classe
de terminale ne s’est pas posé.
Vous me direz : « Grand bien lui fasse. »
Mais allons un peu plus en profondeur
sur l’histoire de Chloé.
En effet, Chloé vient d'une famille
attachée au service public.
Ses deux parents
sont directeurs d’hôpitaux.
Et si le choix d’orientation
ne s’est pas posé,
c’est parce qu’en réalité
il lui a été imposé.
En effet, ses deux parents
voulaient une carrière
qui lui permettrait de tenter les concours
de la haute fonction publique.
Donc l’école de droit s’imposait.
Et si Chloé a su l’entendre
de cette oreille-là hier,
elle compte aujourd’hui
reprendre son destin en main
et faire vivre son ambition
à travers son choix de réorientation.
Mais pour cela, Chloé et Samir vont devoir
mettre en place différentes stratégies,
bien que, comme vous l’avez compris,
ils viennent de milieux différents.
Samir vient d’un milieu plutôt défavorisé
où l’information en matière d’orientation,
et par conséquent pour construire un
choix d’orientation, n’abonde pas,
quand Chloé vient d’un milieu
où l’information abonde.
Abonde, mais dans un sens seulement,
aboutissant non pas à un choix
construit, mais à un choix imposé.
L’un, Samir, a une ambition débordante,
se résumant à la formule de :
« Je veux péter le score »,
quand Chloé a une visée plus pragmatique.
Elle sait vers quoi elle se serait
orientée : le monde du luxe.
Rien à voir avec le service public.
Je vous laisse anticiper la réaction
des parents par ailleurs.
Enfin, autre chose qui compte
tout de même dans nos sociétés :
Samir est un homme, Chloé une femme.
Dans une société où le nombre de femmes
diplômées est toujours plus important
et où pourtant, les postes à
responsabilités trustés par les hommes,
c’est quand même plus important
que ça en a l’air.
Alors Samir et Chloé vont
devoir se déconstruire,
déconstruire les choix hérités
à la naissance,
déconstruire tous ces choix qui leur
ont été soit imposés par leurs parents,
soit qui leur ont été imposés
simplement par manque d’information.
Ils vont devoir entreprendre
différents aspects
que nous avons mis en place
dans l’association Ambition Campus.
Je vous propose de les découvrir
à travers quatre grandes notions
et quatre solutions
pour permettre de concevoir un choix
scolaire qui réponde à ses ambitions.
Première solution qui s’offre
à Samir et Chloé :
optimiser ce que le système,
aussi inégalitaire soit-il,
met à la disposition de ces deux jeunes,
[c’est-à-dire] aller à la rencontre
de leurs professeurs.
En effet, on a tendance à l’oublier,
les professeurs peuvent être
de formidables alliés
dans la construction d’un choix scolaire
qui corresponde aux attentes.
Alors, allez à cette rencontre.
Pas pour négocier 0,5 à l’exercice 3 de
mathématiques au dernier DST en septembre,
mais, cette fois,
pour mieux vous connaître,
pour savoir ce qui peut correspondre
en matière d’ambition scolaire.
Deuxième solution à mettre en place :
laissez-vous porter
par votre entourage proche.
En effet, on a tendance
à l’oublier souvent,
mais l’entourage proche,
et notamment le cercle amical,
peut être un formidable allié
pour booster son ambition,
surtout quand on a seulement 17 ou 18 ans.
Surtout quand on est rempli de doutes.
Et c’est particulièrement
le cas de Samir et de Chloé.
Preuve en est :
personne ne m’a jamais dit que
je ne deviendrais pas joueur de foot,
alors que, soyons honnêtes,
l'histoire est réglée depuis douze ans.
Mieux valait que je me concentre
sur Sciences-Po et la suite.
Qui osera dire à Samir
qu’il rêve trop haut
alors que ses notes
sont justement trop hautes ?
Quel autre ami osera dire à Chloé
qu’elle est trop capricieuse
de vouloir vivre de sa passion ?
Aucun et aucune.
Troisième solution -
et à travers ce TEDx,
on l’inaugure parfaitement -
tournez-vous vers le secteur associatif.
En effet, le système
est loin d’être parfait.
Pourtant, des milliers de bénévoles
mettent en place des dispositifs
pour mieux accompagner des
étudiants en phase de réorientation
ou des lycéens qui cherchent
une orientation choisie.
Ce secteur associatif peut être,
et va être,
un formidable allié pour Samir et Chloé
à travers, pourquoi pas,
un système de mentorat
ou plus largement
une diffusion de l’information.
Enfin, quatrième solution, et peut-être
la plus importante selon moi :
trouvez-vous un role model.
Qu’est-ce qu’un role model ?
Si le concept nous vient tout droit
des États-Unis,
il s’applique en réalité
parfaitement au cas français.
Tous les individus, vous y compris,
moi y compris,
ont tendance à s’identifier
à des groupes de référence
qui occupent des positions sociales
dominantes auxquelles on aspire.
Samir devra trouver un role model
qui, comme lui, a connu
une ascension sociale par l’école.
Pas pour l’imiter à la lettre,
mais surtout pour voir quelle stratégie
lui a pu mettre en place.
Et pour se dire in fine que s'il l'a fait,
Samir pourra le faire demain.
Quant à Chloé, elle devra
trouver un role model
connu ou moins connu, dans son entourage
proche ou entourage éloigné,
pour se dire que si des personnes
ont su aller à l’encontre
d’un choix imposé par les parents,
Chloé aussi peut le faire.
Après avoir mis en place
ces quatre stratégies,
le lycéen Samir et l’étudiante Chloé
ne seront pas encore
au bout de leurs peines
puisque différentes périodes qu’on a
toutes et tous connues vont apparaître.
Tout d’abord,
une première période marquée par
ce qu’on a déjà qualifié d’autocensure.
En effet, vous avez déjà entendu cette
petite voix au moment de faire un choix
en vous disant : « Mais Samir,
tu ne rêves pas trop grand ?
Samir,
tu n’es pas trop ambitieux ?
Samir, est-ce que tu arriveras à assumer
ton choix jusqu’au bout ? »
Ou du côté de Chloé, ce sera :
« Chloé, es-tu sûre, à 18 ans,
de vouloir pour la première fois
aller à l’encontre de tes parents ?
Anticipes-tu la réaction
de tes parents par ailleurs ? »
Pourtant, aucune autre solution
que de passer outre.
Il faudra trouver un allié,
dans son entourage proche
ou dans le monde associatif,
pour passer cette période d’autocensure
et pour arriver à la fin à se dire que,
si je veux me donner les moyens
d’atteindre cet objectif,
d’assumer ce choix,
je mettrai en œuvre toutes les ressources
possibles pour y arriver.
Et ça, Samir et Chloé pourront le faire.
Par ailleurs -
désolé de casser un peu votre enthousiasme
naissant pour Samir et Chloé -
si s’autocensurer est condamnable,
se surestimer lorsqu’on réalise un choix
n’est pas non plus une solution.
Samir et Chloé devront regarder
de manière pragmatique et réaliste
le choix auquel ils consentent,
s’interroger sur tous ces aspects.
Quand Samir prétendra à une grande école,
il devra mettre en balance,
avec sans doute des enjeux financiers.
Quant à Chloé, élève plutôt moyenne,
elle devra mettre en accord
son ambition pour le monde du luxe
avec ses résultats scolaires.
À la suite de cette période marquée
par l’autocensure,
marquée par un requestionnement du choix,
l’autre période qui s’ouvre
pour les lycéens,
après notamment les vœux insérés
dans hier Admission post-bac,
aujourd’hui Parcoursup,
c’est une période de doute,
une période où tout ce qu’on a entrepris
depuis huit mois
pour construire un choix
qui corresponde à nos ambitions
est remis en question,
où on se demande,
sûrement pendant la nuit :
« Est-ce que ce choix est vraiment
un choix qui me correspond ? »
Vous me direz très facilement :
« S’il y a un doute,
c’est qu’il n’y a plus de doute »
Cette phrase est profondément vraie ;
je l’utilise moi-même à outrance.
Sauf qu’elle n’a aucun effet sur
les personnes qui doutent à un instant T.
L’utiliser envers nos jeunes lycéens
Samir ou Chloé n’aura aucun effet.
Ils devront passer cette période
en étant en mesure
d’assumer des arguments
pour justifier tel ou tel choix.
Une fois la période de doute passée,
à travers quelques nuits blanches
qu’on a tous connues
au moment de réaliser un choix,
on s’en est tous remis.
Samir et Chloé s'en remettront.
Une autre période va s’ouvrir
pour Samir et Chloé.
Une période où il faudra assumer
tous les sacrifices à consentir
pour faire vivre ce choix.
Oui, et c’est ce qui me semble
le plus terrible
au moment de réaliser un choix
scolaire ou professionnel,
il y aura des sacrifices, mais des
sacrifices qu’il faut savoir assumer.
Samir se dira, au moment
de prétendre à une grande école,
d’aller vers cinq ans
d’études supérieures :
« Cinq ans d’études supérieures,
c’est quand même 5 ans sans salaire. »
C'est encore cinq ans à vivre
aux crochets de ses parents.
Pourtant, là encore,
et c’est ce qui est formidable avec lui,
Samir pourra compter
sur son cercle amical,
toujours empreint de vannes, mais toujours
là pour le motiver en lui disant :
« Écoute Samir, on a vu tes deux derniers
dimanches sur le terrain de foot.
Concentre-toi sur l’école,
c’est beaucoup mieux pour toi.
Va au bout de tes études et laisse-nous
au moins le terrain de foot. »
Quant à Chloé,
elle se questionnera en se disant :
« Oui, il y aura peut-être
une brouille avec mes parents ;
oui, peut-être que je décevrai
mes parents. »
Elle se dira que c’est peut-être
un choix pour le long terme,
qu’au final ses parents
sauront être fiers d’elle.
Et surtout, son cercle amical
sera encore là pour la motiver :
« Non mais, écoute Chloé,
le monde du luxe,
mais ça se lit sur toi. »
Vous connaissez le cercle amical
un peu fayot de temps en temps,
surtout quand on a 17 ou 18 ans.
Mais in fine, Samir et Chloé
sauront assumer leur choix.
Nous avions donc deux personnages
au début remplis de doutes,
incapables d’assumer un choix,
incapables même de le construire.
Nous avons maintenant deux personnages,
toujours remplis de doutes -
il en faut quand on prépare
un avenir aussi ambitieux -
mais qui ont su faire vivre
leur ambition à travers ce choix.
Vous vous êtes probablement reconnus,
ou pas, dans l’image de Samir et de Chloé,
ou forcément reconnu
une personne de votre entourage
qui doit faire face à un choix.
Comme eux, aidez-les
ou mettez en place vous-même
ces stratégies
afin « d’escape » et d’assumer ce choix.
C'est à votre tour.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)